good morning John we are really really
lucky here's the thing that's kind of
hard for me to think about over the last
ten years we have had 1400 chances to
try something new and in one way or
another sometimes big sometimes super
super tiny we have tried something new
every single video sometimes I humped
things sometimes you ate toilet paper
sometimes I sang songs sometimes we went
to the developing world we've done this
publicly with an audience of varying
sizes and the success of those attempts
has been judged judged by the number of
views those things got what kind of
audiences they attracted whether we
liked doing them how our friends and
families felt whether we thought those
videos were interesting and good and
also by people telling us what they
thought in the comments and those 1,400
chances a lot of those ideas were duds
but some of them were amazing I made a
video with a person I met at a weird
tiny Research Museum in Missoula which
led to the brain scoop becoming nothing
and you and I made videos on the French
Revolution and on the circulatory system
that led to crash course it's impossible
to underestimate the effect that this
has had not just on the kind of stuff I
make but who I have become as a person
if you count scishow and crash course
I've had thousands of chances to try and
figure out who I am in front of good
people who I respect and the kindness of
their judgment their empathy and
compassion and their wit and silliness
of course my own affinity for those
things has made me a kinder more
enthusiastic more compassionate person
we've had thousands of chances to evolve
our content and thousands of chances to
evolve ourselves and this has helped me
clear up the murky waters of what it is
that I really care about it's helped me
find me and a lot of themes have emerged
over the years of us doing this like
areas of fertile soil where I found
stuff that I liked making that I'm good
at making and then I feel like is good
for the world and the people like watch
it sometimes those are formats like
kinds of videos we can make sometimes
they're just ideas ways to consider the
world for me the most important time
that happened was when you distilled so
much of what the world needs right now
into three words when you said imagine
others complexly because it's really
hard but whenever I do it I feel better
and I am better a lot of the projects
that we have created have Wikipedia
pages but this idea has a Wikipedia page
it's part of Wikipedia's essays on
civility that is unusual and it's
amazing but of course it isn't just
other people it's the whole world we
have to imagine the
in its complexity as well and not see
that as a burden but as an opportunity
like a wonderful wonderful thing that we
get to spend our whole lives do and when
I look back at the kind of content that
we make in that we've helped other
people make that thing is always there
in all of it and when I think about what
I want to make in the future if that
isn't there that appreciation for and
excitement about the fact that the world
is not as simple as it might seem I find
myself not wanting to do that thing and
sometimes I don't even know why until I
check in and I'm like yeah it's just cuz
it doesn't do the thing that I want to
be doing that thing imagining complexly
has become a really big part of what we
do and who we are now most the people
watching this probably don't know that
we have a company that produces a bunch
of different content and it has a name
and it's called eco geek and it's called
legal geek because I started a blog in
2005 called eco geek and it's the reason
I've started my first company and when I
did that I had an LLC and I figured I
might as well make all of my other stuff
happened under the same thing and it's
been so long now that I've been using
this name that doesn't really apply
anymore
so this week after years of thinking
about this and never being able to
settle on a name
we are changing our name of the company
that produces the content we have called
it complexly because the world is not
simple and we will never truly
understand our universe or each other or
even ourselves the process is as
powerful as the outcome and the more you
know the more wonderful knowing become
because we want to imagine things
complexly and because we want to help
other people do it - John I'll see you
on Tuesday